I trust you notice the admirable
restraint with which I conducted myself
a lot of Ward was being accepted even
though I was overlooked for my
performance in the big broadcast of 1938
was shown to all Academy members only
last night on The Late Late Show
the next Awards will be presented by a
charming British import the Swedish
John's and a handsome American export
mr. George Hamilton
as we're here to announce the winner for
the best short subject I think we should
be brief mr. Hamilton well I agree the
nominees for Best live action short
subjects are a better male s any
documents the face of Jesus dr. John
Dean Jennings a rooftops of New York
McCarty rush production in association
with Robert Gaffney Seward's the great
ships tickler films very nice very nice
National Film Board of Canada and who is
the women mr. Hamilton
the winner is Seward's the great ships
excepting for supper film studios Dunkel
general left eights gamble
ladies and gentlemen it is not very
often that somebody in my profession is
given an Academy Award and I must
confess that I had nothing whatever to
do is making the film but I'm very proud
and happy to accept it on behalf of the
British makers and I will see that it is
sent to them as quickly as possible
thank you very much
the nominees for cartoon short subjects
are aqua mania warped Disney Productions
Walt Disney producer a be prepared
Warner Brothers Chuck Jones producer
else at the substitute Zagreb films
Nellie's Polly Warner Brothers Chuck
Jones producer Pied Piper of Guadalupe
Warner Brothers Fritz Freeling producer
and who's the winner miss Johnson and
the winner is over accepting form Zagreb
films in Louisville for a sec
on behalf of Zagat in and headline I
would like to thank the members of
Academy for this award
thank you